[Music]
ah
nothing like a fun day of frolicking at
the beach
but venture past the surf
and things
could get ugly
for this is where nightmares lurk
armed with jaws
poison
and unimaginable powers
they say enter at your own risk
but this time it just happens to be true
a scuba diver
dead in the water
there's no sign of trauma
no equipment failure
something down here
could have killed him without leaving a
mark
he was probably checking out the bizarre
life forms in the pacific ocean
but sometimes the bazaar can be deadly
this is an electric ray
it's called the torpedo and it's massive
weighing up to 80 pounds
unlike other rays that swim with fins
the torpedo propels itself like a
stealth bomber
with a shark-like tail
[Music]
and it's armed with an explosive weapon
it stuns and kills with a powerful
electric shock
modified gill muscles contract in waves
victims are trapped under a dome of
terror
then caught in the crossfire of an
electrical current that racks them with
repeated shocks
[Music]
for the most part the ray uses its
weapon to shock fish for easier
swallowing
but when startled by say a diver
the torpedo can unleash up to 50 volts
enough to electrocute and ruin what was
supposed to be a dream vacation
you don't have to be big or electrified
to be a killer
some come disguised in small pretty
packages
the blue ringed octopus is barely bigger
than a golf ball
scouring the tidal pools of the
indo-pacific for treats
[Music]
it's completely deaf
but makes up for it with keen eyes and a
killer sense of
[Music]
smell a crunchy little crab is clueless
[Music]
a quick dash
a quick bite
and then a quick death
the poison paralyzes the hapless
crustacean
after all it's powerful enough to kill a
human in just 90 minutes
it contains tetrodotoxin and it's a
trendy choice among poisonous animals
puffer fish and cone snails use it too
the poison is made by bacteria living in
their saliva glands
and it packs a powerful punch
against prey
and when necessary
predator
[Music]
normally this eight-legged slinky is a
dull yellow with dark rings
but spook it and tiny ink sacks under
its skin rise to the surface and turn
the rings a brilliant neon blue
a vibrant warning
to play with this fella at your own risk
this horde of spiny lobsters is on a
frantic hunt
not for prey
for protection
these horny-eyed shy scavengers are
normally found hiding in cracks and
crevices
but fall storms force them out into the
open where they're vulnerable
[Music]
the leader follows the current to deeper
safer waters
the others use their antenna to play the
following game
eventually they reach the refuge of
their new home
where they can once again
be predators
predators that capitalize on the dead
there's no fight or flea left in this
guy
so all kinds of critters belly up to the
dinner table
for once lobsters are safe in a shark's
presence
make quick work of the carcass
leaving only bits of bone and teeth
behind as evidence it ever existed in
the first place
[Music]
this little blue fish doesn't look very
deadly
[Music]
guess we're not talking about the little
blue fish
stonefish cover their mules up just like
a vacuum cleaner
in one massive goal
sure it may look slow
an easy target for a predator
think again
13 poison tipped spines adorn its dorsal
fin
and each contains a mix of paralyzing
neurotoxins and tissue destroying
myotoxins
no wonder the stonefish is considered
the most venomous fish in the world
it's a lethal threat to humans too
especially since it looks like an
ordinary rock in the ocean
the stone fish
an extraordinary killer
this guy's so ugly
he's cute
the striated frog fish aka hairy frog
fish
[Music]
a good hair day it isn't
but hunting's what's on this frogfish's
mind
[Music]
he settles down to the perfect
camouflage
then goes to town
whipping a worm-like lure around on top
of his head
the frog fish
is fishing
[Music]
anything brave enough to investigate
isn't long for this world
[Music]
with skills like that
who cares about bad hair
some have skills
others
have equipment
moire eels hide in rocks and reefs until
nighttime
when they slink out to hunt
jaw popping helps them breathe and makes
them look ferocious
two nostrils draw in water over a highly
developed olfactory gland which detects
the scent of prey floating by
here's where the equipment comes in
the outer jaws seize the fish
then a set of inner jaws go to work
yes moire eels have not one but two sets
of jaws
the second set acts as a claw machine
and pulls the food into the eel's
stomach
[Music]
the puffer fish puffs up to double its
size
masterful move
the eel is determined to get his dinner
but it's an exercise in futility
the only way to win this battle is with
a third set of jaws
[Music]
maybe things will go a little easier for
this peacock flounder who's eyeballing a
nearby female
[Music]
he thrusts his pectoral fin high in the
air to get her attention
but that can also get the attention of
predators
[Music]
the more he tries
the more she rejects him
typical
it's a disastrous state
and about to get worse
a huge snapper is sniffing
[Music]
around luckily
he's curious
not hungry
nothing like a near-death experience to
get you in the mood
[Music]
the two flutter around releasing
fertilized eggs into the water
then quickly go back to their separate
corners on the sea floor
[Music]
legend has it that sea monsters live
here
in the cold dark waters of the pacific
and guess what
they do
[Music]
this beast is a giant humble squid and
if you think it's a candidate for
calamari
check this out
they can grow
as large as a man
without warning they rise from the
darkness to feed on fish at the surface
sometimes they look like ghostly spirits
they turn white by opening and closing
sacks of pigment in their skin
when alarmed or aggressive
they turn red
as in
beware
their nickname
red devils
[Music]
few willingly tangle with humboldt squid
but this filmmaker descends into the
darkness to capture one-of-a-kind
footage
[Music]
at first they're curious
then
they turn aggressive
in the attack of the killer squid
tentacles grab his mask and regulator
threatening his air supply
beating them back he makes for the
surface
it's not a dream or a legend
it's real
a real life nightmare
exotic
majestic
and completely toxic
[Music]
the lionfish has long flowing fins to
hide an arsenal of poisonous spines
and a flashy pattern to send a clear
message to predators
look
but don't touch
people tend to ignore the warning which
explains the forty thousand cases of
lionfish poisonings every year
[Music]
symptoms range from severe pain to
convulsions and even heart complications
[Music]
armed with a gaping mouth and voracious
appetite
they cockily prowl the reefs for fish
and invertebrates
the prey is herded into position
[Music]
again
a doomed little blue fish
confused
cornered
and consumed
[Music]
then they saunter off to search for
their next course
without a lot of predators to worry
about life's pretty good for these spiky
sea creatures
tube feet wriggle
red stalks bristle
those who touch it
instantly regret it
this is the fire urchin
like all sea urchins the fire urchin is
an econoderm
a family of slow and spiny invertebrates
other members include sea cucumbers and
starfish
in fact a sea urchin's body design is a
lot like a balled up starfish
its plate covered top has hundreds of
spines dotted with poison filled sacks
that burst on contact
if that's not enough
they have another defensive weapon
hidden in their spines
jaws
they aren't real mouths but they look
like it
these grasping appendages clean collect
food and defend
with even more poison
this guy is only about eight inches wide
but he packs a hefty punch
so stay clear of the fiery red ball
or you might get burned
let's face it
this shark looks like a freak
what's with the huge flat head and
bulging eyes
hammerheads may be on the odd side of
attractive
but they're mysterious
fascinating
and deadly
a huge olfactory cavity allows them to
smell in 3d
and snatch prey without even seeing it
so they're master hunters
even in the dark
special pores called the ampullae of
lorenzini detect electromagnetic fields
given off by other animals
and hammerheads have more than any other
shark or ray in the world
they can pick up electrical currents
down to a hundred millionth of a volt
like the beating heart of a fish
or a stingray gliding over sand
and now for a slick move
called the pin and pivot
enter the spotted eagle ray one of the
hammerhead's favorite snacks
[Music]
in an instant one entire wing is gone
and it's left in a pool of blood
the shark actually uses its big flat
noggin to pin its prey to the ocean
floor
then it rotates and pivots to pick it up
and chomp it up
so it may look funny but the hammerhead
is an evolutionary wonder
an agile crafty
intelligent killer
[Music]
coral reefs attract some of the most
beautiful fish in the world
then there's this guy
the great barracuda
and what it lacks and looks it makes up
for with speed and wildiness
one of its best talents is ambushing
prey
when the barracuda finds a target it
slices through the water
then slices through its prey
and not with one row of teeth
try too
[Music]
an inner row of large dagger-like teeth
clamps down and holds it in place
then an outer row of smaller teeth cuts
it to pieces
it's an effective design that works well
on fish
or people
the great barracuda is responsible for
two deaths and blamed for many more
so unless you want to end up on its
dinner plate
stay out of the way
it might come as a surprise to see a
seal in a nightmare show
but it's no mistake
especially when it comes to the leopard
seal
they out hunt every other seal out there
and even like to feed on their own kind
reaching 12 feet long and 1 000 pounds
they're one of the antarctic's top
predators
and they back up their reputation with
huge teeth that they sink into krill
fish
and
penguins
especially penguins
leopard seals top out at 25 miles per
hour
but penguins are more maneuverable
so the leopard seal has no other choice
but to change his game
he flops onto the ice for a land ambush
[Music]
finally it looks like dinner's on the
table
unless you're smart enough to play dead
until your killer looks the other way
in a genius escape this penguin scoots
himself free
this one
doesn't
[Music]
it's big
slow
and certainly not the scariest of
predators
but give it some credit
loggerhead turtles have massive heads
a powerful set of jaws
and only have to surface every 30
minutes or so to breathe
[Music]
a sharp beak transforms it into a
prehistoric monster for a slipper
lobster
the outmatched crustacean is armed with
little to defend itself
so all it can do is try to outswim the
turtle
a battle of the slowest
begins with a chase
and ends
with a chomp
[Music]
it's a ray
that looks like a shark
that looks like a tool
and it's performing an underwater
version of texas chainsaw massacre
with that huge saw on the end of its
face
it's called a rostrum
and all sawfish have one
some can be as long as a person
but no matter the size they all pretty
much do the same thing
defend against predators like sharks and
detect prey with electromagnetic sensing
pores
which comes in handy in murky water
but what we all want to know is can the
sawfish actually use its saw like a saw
scientists say yes
sawfish slash and stun prey with quick
powerful swipes
then pass over it and swallow it whole
a delicious end to a real life horror
flick
some nightmares aren't just scary
they're sick
[Music]
notice the pearl fish perfectly
camouflaged in the sea grass
spook it and it relies on an extreme and
disgusting survival tactic
enter the sea cucumber
a spiky crawling feeding tube
that actually provides a safe haven for
the pearl fish
when threatened the fish locates the
cucumber's rear exit
and then inserts itself
tail first up into the intestines
the pearl fish is safe
the sea cucumber was too humiliated to
comment
[Music]
they come in all shapes and sizes
colorful
blind
brainless blobs
[Music]
most are pretty harmless
not this one
the box jellyfish is a highly evolved
killer
its venom ranks among the most deadly in
the world
[Music]
they don't just drift
they move
six eyes sit clustered on all four
corners of their bell
24 in total
[Music]
up to 15 tentacles grow up to 10 feet
long and each has about 5 000 stinging
cells which were triggered by this
doomed fish
toxins paralyzed the victim to avoid a
struggle that could damage the box's
delicate tentacles
then
dinner is served
a frozen treat locked in an agonizing
screen
[Music]
the poison is also lethal to humans
attacking the heart nervous system and
skin cells
victims can drown from shock or die of
heart failure
beaches in australia are sometimes
forced to close for the summer months
due to box jellyfish balloons
because the worst danger
is the one you don't see coming
it's the one you see clear as day
[Music]
powering through the water up to 30
miles an hour
killer whales are hard to miss
and they didn't get that nickname for
nothing
four inch long teeth rip through their
favorite prey with ease
they average over 20 feet long and weigh
as much as six tons
but killer whales rely on a lot more
than size and speed to be killers
try teamwork
and tactics
sometimes in groups of 40.
this time the target is a seal
and is used for target practice
a teaching lesson again and again
when practice is over
so is the seal
even land can't stop their voracious
appetites
the hungry orcas propelled themselves
onto the beach to snatch up sea lions
despite the risk of being stranded
but not all sea lions meet a quick end
one unfortunate pup is brought to the
juvenile whales alive for them to once
again practice their hunting skills
the killer whale
a top
predator with a killer appetite
and now
a mantis shrimp interlude whose eyes are
the most complex of the animal kingdom
they can see infrared ultraviolet
polarized light and focus with
trinocular vision for enhanced depth
perception
all the better to smash
spear
and eat you with
like there isn't enough venom in the
ocean already
the banded sea crate is more deadly than
most cobras
they're descended from the same ancestor
but these guys are specially designed
for life in the water
[Music]
its right lung runs nearly the entire
length of its three foot long body so it
can hold its breath for about 30 minutes
a paddle-shaped tail propels it to the
sea floor where it can scope out its
favorite prey
eels
yes
a snake acting like a fish hunts a fish
then acts like a snake
and he's caught a whiff of something
tasty
[Music]
it latches on to the eel's face to keep
it from squirming while the poison does
its work
neurotoxins paralyze the eel and
myotoxins destroy muscle tissue
eventually the eel loses the fight and
suffocates
which frees up the banded secret to
slither off for another meal
at first glance it seems that we're
moving on to a lighter note
everyone loves cute clownfish right
right
but maybe not so much for their big
creepy friend right behind them
a sea anemone
[Music]
clownfish are immune to the sea anemones
paralyzing stingers
thanks to a thick coat of mucus
so they're protected from any predatory
fish
in return
clownfish keep the sea anemone free of
parasites
which makes them in a way
friends with benefits
[Music]
still feeling the love
[Music]
not all predators are fast or agile or
sneaky
you don't have to be if you're patient
like the cone snail
although it doesn't look like it has
much choice
at least it's armed with a rock hard
shell to protect it as it scours the sea
floor
between its eye stalks is a long siphon
that sniffs out prey
like this camouflaged blenny fish
a long tube called the proboscis edges
toward the fish
inside is the snail's secret weapon
a poison tipped tooth that acts like a
harpoon
the bellini is completely oblivious
then
completely paralyzed
the cone snail gulps it down hole
so patience can be a virtue
patience
and poison
[Music]
maybe heading to a river is safer
or not
normally catfish gets served up on our
tables
but it looks like those are turning
meet the wells catfish
a monster that can reach nine feet long
and weigh in at 200 pounds
a normal fishing pole won't get the job
done
legends tell of humongous specimens
dragging fishermen to their doom
[Music]
okay so maybe you won't get eaten alive
by what you made for dinner
but the fish are being imported to
rivers like this one in spain
and they grow like gangbusters
long whiskers covered with chemical
receptors feel and taste things on the
riverbed
so they're expert hunters
they devour the living
and scavenge the dead
bad for the local fish
good for the wells catfish
maybe the focus should shift back to the
legends
they're masters of disguise
with eight arms
hundreds of suckers
three hearts
smarts
and an ink sack
what more could a cephalopod want
[Music]
octopuses are boneless creatures
soft and squishy
so they can stuff themselves into the
smallest of cracks and holes
then their hunting skills kick in
a crab
doesn't stand a chance
[Music]
to see how pliable they really are
we put an octopus to the test
[Music]
it stretches and squeezes through
tunnels as small as a quarter
in its natural habitat disability helps
it ambush prey
and hide from predators
it sniffs out hidden food in the tanks
and even figures out a way through the
maze to find dinner
forget about locks
this guy easily opens the tank sealed
covers
and escapes
now that's what we call a double o
octopus
a jaw fish
sounds spooky right
well consider this
he's not tossing his cookies
he's tossing his family
this mouth-broding expectant father is
aerating the eggs to help them develop
he'll keep them in his mouth until
they're big enough to swim on their own
but let's face it one swallow and he's a
mass murderer
speaking of murderers
piranhas have gotten a bad rap for
decades
but they earned it
really
shark-like feeding frenzies
teeth that puncture shear and strip
victims down to nothing but bare bones
in games of up to a hundred they search
for easy pickings in the amazon river
like this unfortunate baby egret
who rings the dinner bell the second he
hits the water
monster jaws come running
[Music]
it's over in minutes
but piranhas are more than just frenzied
predators
they scavenge carcasses
and even eat plants
so they school in large numbers for
hunting and protection
at least there aren't any records of a
person being eaten alive by piranhas
not yet anyway
[Music]
not all underwater critters live life at
a frantic pace
[Music]
some like to lie around like slugs
literally
[Music]
sea slugs or nudibranchs are tiny slimy
and pretty
pretty poisonous
some produce poisons
others absorb poisons from their prey
this sea swallow even chows down on the
toxic stingers of the portuguese man of
war
[Music]
the nudibranch absorbs them into its
body to use for its own defense
so don't be fooled by pretty
sometimes it can be pretty deadly
they're gigantic
with massive heads
and teeth the size of a human hand
they have the biggest brain of any
creature on earth
and even provided inspiration for
melville's classic novel
moby dick
[Music]
sperm whales spend the majority of their
time looking for food
but considering they need more than a
ton of it a day
it's no wonder
fish and squid are their favorite snacks
so with the kick of their powerful fluke
they sink a mile below the surface
where they'll hang out for up to 90
minutes
[Music]
there's almost no light
so they send out powerful ultrasonic
clicks
the returning echoes reveal both the
size and location of prey
like the giant squid
we've seen what they can do to a diver's
face
but a real-life battle between a sperm
whale and a giant squid has never been
captured on film
sucker marks on their skin and squid
beaks in their stomachs are evidence
that the war is being raged and probably
being repeatedly lost by the squid
there's no way to know for sure but our
money's on the sperm whale
black groupers have some game of their
own they pretty much suck down anything
that gets too close
except for these gobies who luckily for
them provide a special service
[Music]
this patch of coral is a full-service
cleaner station
a tiger grouper pulls in and the gobies
go to work
picking off parasites and dead skin
the fish is cleaned and buffed to a
lethal shine
the gobi spared from being gulped down
by the grouper
at least for now
it's one of the deadliest predators in
the water
fresh water that is
and it may look like the wells catfish
is cousin but this guy's far more
dangerous
the electric eel
[Music]
it prowls the murky ponds and river
basins of south america
and just one shot can knock a horse
clear off its feet
each eight foot long eel can generate
six or seven hundred volts
that's more than five times a standard
u.s electrical outlet
if a human's on the receiving end
sharp stabbing pain uncontrollable
muscle spasms and even cardiac arrest
can occur from just a few jolts
so what's the secret to producing this
much electricity
the eel's organs are jammed into the top
fifth of its body
the rest contains roughly six thousand
specialized cells called electrocytes
charged ions flow into each of these
cells and create a current
that can kill prey without even touching
it
[Music]
the electric eel has no teeth
it's not particularly fast
its gills can't extract enough oxygen
from the water so it has to surface
every 10 minutes or so to gulp down air
and if that wasn't enough
it's pretty much blind
but the small electrical pulses it
generates helps the eel navigate rivers
detect prey
and predators
this juvenile caiman thinks he's about
to get an easy meal
all he gets is electrocuted
but that doesn't stop him
he goes for another
then makes a smart escape
the eel remains master of its domain
[Music]
they're poisonous
double jawed
clever
and downright deadly
all of the world's waters are filled
with critters that can kill
so beware
the next time you go in the water
you may have an underwater nightmare of
your own
[Music]
[Music]
you